this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands 500 weapons from
throughout history and this week he's
taking a look at the post-apocalyptic
arsenal of Joel and Ellie in The Last of
Us Part one right there is some
significant recoil going on here which
would no doubt be improved if he would
put the thing in his shoulder make sure
to subscribe and let us know what other
games or guns you'd like to see Jonathan
break down in the comments section down
below right let's take a look at more
weapons from The Last of Us Part One
that's what she believes
[Music]
I'd sneak out right first hand gone up
it's very clearly
a Browning high power gp35 or whatever
you'd like to call it has a few names
however there's some different there are
some differences so it's shorter it's
more like a compact variant which there
isn't of the true Browning high power
you'll find them for the double action
spin-off so it's too short effectively
and there's to me the grip shape is a
little bit more reminiscent of the
current
Browning high power that is not actually
Browning high power think of it as a
1911 in nine millimeter with more rounds
because it sort of is but not really
very popular in all aspects this example
that I've picked is just a really nice
beautifully finished Circa 1951 example
of the Browning high power
okay gameplay wise Lottery recoil a
lottery coil Joel's hands or maybe it's
his Jack Bauer style grip there but his
recoil control is not great his grip is
good I I would expect that sort of
implied recoil more so from a like a
magnum level revolver or something it's
fine it's a minor thing the graphics
have definitely been bumped up from from
what I remember quite a lot of detail
there in this this view we can see the
rifling grooves in the barrel they are a
bit too pronounced but they are
beautifully rendered
and then I can see from this angle
another bit of Liberty creative Liberty
taken with the design and it's the one
place where our example here has got a
bit of worn finish is the front edge of
the trigger guard front corner where it
shouldn't have a corner it should be
rounded almost like an extended 1911
trigger guard which is kind of what it
is more more of a later era so what we
could say this is is a Browning high
power clone made by some fictional
third-party manufacturer so we get a
nice convenient view of the back of
Joel's head as he uh carries out some
some sleight of hand there and magically
makes his magazine longer he's got a
he's got an extended base plate fair
enough but then when the magazine is in
the gun and extended the actual body of
the magazine has magically extended
adding a base plate does not stretch the
metal tube of the magazine
thank you
all right another mystery gun here this
doesn't seem to be based on anything
real almost looks homemade or made in a
workshop or something of that nature the
frame looks like it's made out of a
U-shaped piece of metal or at least it's
been milled out to create a hinge point
so it's break open and a very few modern
break open revolvers because they're not
strong enough it's just it's not really
worth making break open revolvers
because a swing out cylinder is is more
efficient anyway and it makes the frame
weaker if you're trying to chamber
Magnum cartridges so they're pretty rare
very very little in the way of top break
revolvers and this is not that this is
something else we've gone from a single
chamber well yeah chamber insert instead
of a cylinder to the upgrade here which
is a double chambered cylinder sort of
but there doesn't seem to be the
clearance for it to actually revolve
it's too tall and the angles don't make
sense that could not spin in the frame
and I I'm I haven't slowed it down I
can't see whether it's actually
revolving in the frame anyway way but
needless to say it couldn't work if it
didn't so I assume it is so it must be
clipping through itself to achieve that
there are conversions to single shot for
revolvers that you put a block chamber
into that Gap instead if you if all
you're trying to do is Achieve single
shot accuracy they're quite rare but
they do exist this thing upgraded is is
something else it's like a two-shot
revolver that doesn't make much sense
I'm not sure what's going on with the
ejector rod and spring being exposed
there as well that's also a bit strange
yeah another Oddball weapon
bolt action rifle big feature of the of
these games of course and also in the TV
series Pretty clearly based on Remington
700 albeit with the usual changes in
detail we have a couple of Remington
700s in the collection scoped neither of
them were in quite configuration that I
saw so I've grabbed this one instead
which is in completely the different a
different configuration but is quite
unusual
um this is the Remington 700 e-tronics
and it has an electronic trigger has an
LED in the stock here to show you that
you have battery power and there's an on
off switch that's operated by a key
in the semi-pistol grip there the key is
attached to the label and when that's on
you have it's a micro switch in the
trigger I don't know if that will come
through on the microphone probably not I
would say it's experimental it's not it
was it was brought to Market in the
early 2000s didn't do very well but not
for once we're trying and yeah we'll see
we'll see whether it comes back it's
completely relevant to to the game
because we that is a very conventional
Remington 700 with a mechanical trigger
clearly let's do this
foreign
I haven't run and grabbed one for you I
think you know the Remington 870 Shotgun
by now iconic pump action shotgun design
that's obviously what this is the uh
trigger guard is too thick and chunky
both for the design of the 870 and
really for what it needs to be all it
has to do is stop your finger from
touching the trigger too easily or from
anything else
um touching it that's really really
chunky but the overall design
um yeah pretty clearly 870. like real
real detail stuff but the extractor
that's on the on the side of the ball to
the front there it's got a bit of
unnecessary detail and the way it's
modeled on there it makes me think that
um
it's not understood how how it works or
what its job is which is completely
understandable and fair enough
uh effects wise handling wise it feels
big and powerful and Punchy uh looks
good looks like a handful actually to to
try to with it with the slow reload and
the relatively limited capacity to make
sure you take out those not zombies
before they get too close to you when
you do hit them or a person it's it's
devastating too devastating and it's
fair to say I like the the visual
interest of that level of interaction
shall we say as much as the next
third person shooting player but um
blowing entire heads off such that
there's nothing there at all and an arm
at the same time in one case
shotguns are very effective and they're
not that effective
foreign
type rifle or something very close to it
the proportions are all a little bit off
I think only a bit so the height of the
lower receiver is massive compared to
what it what it ought to be the way it
kind of the up the upper looks looks
fine to me I don't know it's it's close
enough it's absolutely close enough um
for an AR they're big I don't know it
feels to me like they might have
um sort of upres the original model I
don't know how close this is I can't
remember sorry I did review it but I
can't remember how close it is to the
original game model but it's not
not that faithful to an actual AR
absolutely close enough uh the sling
swivel being attached to the side of the
low receiver not good placement and it's
not something you'll see on a real gun
and would interfere with how it works as
well in terms of attaching it to the
side overall impression yeah it's
basically an M4 something close to it
without getting into Super nerdy detail
about it what it isn't I don't think is
one of these video game clutches where
they take two real rifles in this case
and smudge them smoosh them together
such that they don't look like one or
the other they haven't done that they've
gone for their take on an AR in this
universe
foreign
oh dear Joel has a severe case of the
Marcus phoenixes here in that uh and
he's not not just that he's hiding
behind chest High walls he's not
shouldering his rifle now at least in
Gears of War they have the excuse that
they mostly didn't have butt stocks here
he does but he's not shouldering the
rifle he's not using the sights no okay
depending on your experience level you
might look over the gun and aim more
instinctively but there's still no
reason to not pull that stock into your
shoulder for stability because that's
going to improve your shooting
regardless of what you do with the sides
it's a an odd choice to have him just
hold the gun out in front of him like
he's never used a rifle before
right there is some significant recoil
going on here
um which would no doubt be improved if
he would put the thing in his gelder
um there's so little recoil relatively
speaking on a 556 rifle that even if you
were to hold it away from your shoulder
like that I don't think you'd experience
that much recoil because a game likes to
not compensate for the recoil as you
instinctively would as a shooter shot
anything at all you you would you would
anticipate it coming up after the first
couple of rounds at least and try to do
something to bring it back down games
often don't do that so The Recoil is
going to look excessive on most things
but it this proportionately speaking
compared to the other weapons in the
game
I think it's too much going on but yeah
maybe that's because of how he's holding
the thing
thank you
right flamethrower very improvised lots
of pipe work commercially available gas
tank screwed onto the bottom there and
it looks like I don't know butane
lighter fluid type igniter at the rear
with a pipe conveying that to the front
so far so good and a bicycle brake lever
to or maybe a motorbike break or clutch
lever I'm not sure that releases the
stream of fuel at the front which is
really nicely modeled in terms of being
um unlit as it emerges if you see what I
mean and then igniting on the way out so
you get that short jet of fuel and then
the flame effect looks really good can't
quite figure out how it's supposed to
work because that igniter seems to
terminate in a rag clamped over the end
which is one way to do a flamethrower
you set light to that oily rag at the
end and that's your ignition source and
then you spray your high pressure of
fuel over the top of it and it and it
lights but there's a sort of Disconnect
between
the igniter along the bottom and the
actual fuel jetting out of the into that
cage on the top if someone else can
figure this out please do comment but in
the in the brief clip that I've just
seen I couldn't wrap my head around it
looks like it should work I'm not
convinced that it does mechanically
speaking uh the the effect of the the
flame it looks looks good I think the
the fact that you can semi light someone
on fire and they're struggling to put
themselves out it's pretty grim
but I haven't seen that done before
people are either on fire and dying in
games or they're absolutely fine so the
idea that you can wound someone with
with flame is kind of impressive and
different in reality of course if your
whole right arm is that scorched you're
probably going to rethink your life
choices and not come after the the
shooter so the the fact that they can
shrug off these Grievous injuries and
still keep fighting until they do get
killed is less realistic obviously
protect it inside
[Applause]
okay um Ellie here with her sidearm
which I think is modeled on the Walter
P5 a sort of successor to the P38 and
this is the P5 compact which I think is
closer to version on screen it's quite
it's still quite a chunky pistol despite
being in this case compact it's not like
a not quite as chunky in the hand as a
Beretta 92 maybe not even a Glock
because it is single stack but um or
someone who's a bit younger a small
framed it's it's quite a handful still
but they represent that I think the way
the the character's hand is is sort of
Joni just wrapped around the grip seems
to be what they're going for it wasn't a
perfect fit in her hand in the view that
I had initially like the the fingers
were sort of clipping through the gun
slightly an unusual choice you don't
really see this in in much otherwise
ha
foreign
Accuracy International Arctic Warfare
Magnum or at least something very close
to it this is an A3 or what's left of
one oh if I if I'm looking at this
correctly the version of the in the game
is lacking the thumb hole stock you can
see where this should
connect to it to a what's a missing
piece of stock here and all you have is
the thumb hole to put your hand through
so it's a folding folding but stop press
the catch and it falls for transports uh
and locks into itself as well along the
left side but if this one's missing big
chunks as you can see so this ironically
makes it look more like the game gun a
bit missing its scope as well that's not
unusual when we receive things from
trials and this is from a trial of some
sort we have to find out what hopefully
we will and so it's missing various bits
magazine is missing but you can see it's
a it is in fact the Magnum variant it's
uh 338 lap or Magnum uh we see a
difference here with the bolts handle so
the bolt handle on the gain gun is Tiny
really tiny and straight whereas the AI
is cranked for easy access and it has a
much larger knob obvious grasping
purpose it is but we can see the big The
Fairly iconic squared off AI cocking
piece here the fluted barrel is visible
as is that somewhat distinctive muzzle
device as well which is a chambered
break with a thread for a suppressor and
they are used with suppressors now this
is missing a bipod as well but in the
game this thing is fitted to a sniping
monopod fixed bolted to the floor
monopod makes it very very stable less
flexible because you have to detach it
from the from the mount to to use it
more flexibly so I guess Joel has come
across this in situ and is turning it
against the occupants always nice to see
an AI in a game you know they are one of
the few British Firearms or British
military Firearms makers so
um good to see them represented thanks
everyone for watching those were the
guns of The Last of Us Part One
retrospectively titled part one I'm
looking forward to getting hold of that
game myself I have to say I hope you
enjoyed it as always there are numerous
links in the description relating to
what we do here at the Royal Army we'd
appreciate it if you checked that out
I've got an article out at the moment in
our Max Journal which is also in the
description as well if you'd like to
check out the link over there it does
cost money but I hope you think it's
worth it we will see you again next time
on this very series